[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to indie world my name's ted and
i'm elise
and we're here to check out a fresh
selection of indie games coming to the
nintendo
switch system there are lots of great
games out there
and we're here to help you find your
next favorites
so let's get started
hey it's me alex i'm okay i met this
girl
this boy the loser at the diner at the
gas station
in the mountains they were hitchhiking
driving they were escaping to the border
looking for someone called zoe john
jared sonja i'm running from the police
learning from some bad guys they helped
me
played games with me they stole my money
and they made me realize
that i have to come back home i have to
make my own way to help the brigades
[Applause]
where am i road 13 road 42
road 67 road 96.
[Music]
[Music]
i'm excited to see where these roads
lead in this procedural story driven
game from digix art
take on the roles of different teenagers
and hit the open road for a path to
freedom
on this perilous trip you'll meet
characters from all walks of life
and learn their intertwining stories
some folks may help you out
others might impede your journey with
thousands of potential paths to take
the decisions you make both big and
small can drastically alter your
experience
what happens if you take the bus take it
easy
or call a taxi
in the end all roads have to lead
somewhere you're not lying
are you there are many roads
which one will you take road 96
drives onto nintendo switch later this
year
[Music]
hi i'm neil i go by aerial night online
and the creator and developer of ariel
knights never yield
a narrative runner that captures the
spirit of classic games in the genre
with a few new features
and a lot of style i created this game
in detroit to make space for myself in
the game industry which previously
refused to make space for me
with the help of some of my amazing
friends who created something that
represents much more
i'm proud to announce that aerial
knights never yield will be coming to
nintendo
switch which means you can free run your
way to victory to the beat of a dope
soundtrack
at home or on the go please enjoy this
look
at aerial nice never yield
i keep
[Music]
bringing it back in full effect to the
next running with the best never missing
a step
from the east to the west i stay fresh
out finesse some progress with no stress
in and out of the city i get busy they
can't get me i can't be stopping on top
[Music]
100
[Music]
i gotta say this definitely isn't your
typical runner
a 3d side scroller with parkour action
set in a futuristic tokyo-style detroit
sign me up run jump slide
and dash through the city as the
protagonist wall-e
to save what's left of the future and
you'll no doubt be head bopping to the
amazing soundtrack by detroit artist
daniel wilkins
with vocals from artists around the
world
aerial knights never yield slides onto
nintendo's switch may 19th
a demo will be available on nintendo
eshop later today
[Music]
annapurna interactive publisher of
florence
and what remains of edith finch have a
couple more artistic gems headed to
nintendo switch
let's take a look
jack everybody thinks you're me
we have to face the facts here we are
ever gonna be the same
again
[Music]
why are you only speaking to me and not
the others
i bent over backwards trying to keep
this family together but what can i do
with this
[Music]
this is better dad
you've been playing anything
this is the next frontier now show them
what you're made of
how do you know what to keep and what to
get rid of
there's some things that i can't let go
they transport me to the past to distant
memories
and dreams that cascade into one another
before i know it i'm pulled back to the
present
standing here alone
[Music]
last stop arrives on nintendo switch
july 2021.
hindsight comes to nintendo switch later
this year
on behalf of everyone here at roll seven
i'm stoked to announce our next title
our new game is a vibrant action
platformer taking you on a journey
across the island of radland on a quest
to meet
the legendary skate gods skateboarding
is a sport and an art form with so much
space for creativity and expression
and that's something we really wanted to
capture in our new game
we're embracing the weird wonderful and
diverse sides of skateboarding
in a game that's all about going on a
road trip with your friends finding
crazy spots and of course skating
everything in sight
the team have put a lot of love into
this project and we're really excited to
share it with you so without further ado
here's a look at holly ollie world
the latest title in the ali ali series
from roll seven
is just off the rails tear up the
streets of radland
and search for the mystical skate gods
on your quest for nirvana
in this slick action platformer the
developers have created a silky smooth
gameplay experience
with super tight controls and level
design that flows with your combos
there are so many tricks to master that
even a legendary skater would tremble
there's no need to aim for precision all
the time though
down for more chilled out experience
explore multiple paths to the game's
levels
along the way you'll get to meet
colorful characters
take on quirky side quests and discover
all the hidden secrets of this weird and
gorgeous skating utopia
[Music]
ride through radland in ali ali world
launching on nintendo's switch
this winter
[Music]
hello everyone
is
[Music]
[Music]
which
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this hand-drawn art style i've never
seen anything like it
and wow 400 days
in real time you don't
actually have to play this adventure
game to see how it ends
but that doesn't mean you should leave
this little guy all alone
this is a shade the last servant of a
king who once ruled an underground
kingdom
explore dark caves complete time-based
puzzles
and collect items as you long for him to
awaken
the longing comes to nintendo switch
later today
what's our next game there is no game uh
all right ben no really the game is
actually called
there is no game it's a point-and-click
comedy adventure filled with riddles and
puzzles
there's a broader story here in this
non-game as well
let's not ruin the fun though just know
this if you're looking for something
different
something experimental that's full of
surprises then look no further
there is no game wrong dimension
launches on nintendo switch
later today
hi this is jaya from tribute games and
i'm cereal from the tenure
today we're very excited to announce
teenage mutant ninja turtles
shredders revenge for nintendo switch
system this game is a side scrolling
beat them up
we took direct inspiration from the
classic teenage mutant ninja turtle
games like turtles and time
we're using the classic and famous 87
design with colorful pixel art
we are really happy to have the game
coming to nintendo switch
as the platform and features fit the
project perfectly
we hope you like this trailer as much as
we do see you
in dimension x
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa did we just flash back to
the 80s
even better this is a new game that
proudly celebrates its roots
the game is reminiscent of classic
arcade beat-em-ups
and it's got a blend of retro and modern
visuals
this side scroller reunites our four
favorite turtles
as they kick some serious shell dive
into this bodacious
game developed by tribute games and
published by dotemu
who also published streets of rage 4 and
wonder boy the dragon's trap
cowabunga teenage mutant ninja turtles
shredders revenge comes to nintendo
switch
later this year
chris tales from colombian developers
dreams
incorporated and sick draws inspiration
from classic
and modern jrpgs what especially stands
out about it is the time traveling
aspect of gameplay
you can shift time during combat which
can have a variety of effects
like making enemies younger and thus
easier to defeat
while exploring this handcrafted dark
fairy tale world you'll recruit a
diverse cast of allies and discover
new realms such as the shining kingdom
of crystalis
can you stop the empress from destroying
the world chris tales lands on nintendo
switch
july 20th
showcasing a stylized japanese aesthetic
getsu fumadan delivers a dynamic hack
and slash
roguelite experience filled with
perilous dungeons
fierce boss battles and intense
skill-based
combat delve into the depths of the
underworld while mastering a diverse
range of weapons and other worldly
powers
to drive back the dark forces dwelling
within
getsu fumadan undying moon comes to
nintendo's switch
next year
a
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for a grand adventure
look
no further than aztec forgotten gods
it tells the story of ashley a
courageous woman
who battles colossal deities the game
puts aztec mythology
and futuristic technology front and
center
as ashley you'll gain powerful arm
upgrades
traverse different areas within a modern
mesoamerican metropolis
and encounter all sorts of characters to
uncover
ancient secrets however sometimes the
truth
is best left forgotten aztec forgotten
gods
soars onto the nintendo switch system
fall
[Music]
foreign
be
[Music]
[Music]
skull the hero slayer is a 2d fast
action roguelite where you take on an
entire army to rescue your king
and the best part to progress in the
game you'll need a swap abilities
which is done by swapping heads
with 90 playable characters i mean heads
each with their own special abilities
plus numerous items and upgrades there
are certainly enough possibilities here
to make your head spin
so get ahead literally
skull the hero slayer launching on
nintendo switch
summer 2021
we're nearing the end of today's
showcase before we go
there are several more indie games we'd
like to show you please
take a look
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
ready to start your next indie adventure
on nintendo switch
head on over to nintendo eshop or
nintendo.com
for our indie world sale available later
today
that's all for today's indie world
showcase we hope you're looking forward
to these games
on behalf of everyone at nintendo we'd
like to thank
our talented community of partners and
developers
for bringing their games to the nintendo
switch system
and thank you to all of our amazing fans
for tuning in
to stay up to date with all the latest
news from indie world please be sure to
follow our official twitter account
at indieworld n a until next time
happy gaming
[Music]
uh we spoke too soon we actually
have one more game to show you
welcome welcome first we're gonna have a
little walk tonight folks
reported strange interruptions in their
radio broadcasters
can you hear me
riley are you there
you